ja die intensivmediziner in deutschland
sie haben sich heute mit einem
dramatischen brief an die
bundesregierung gewandt und haben gesagt
wenn nicht sofort etwas passiert dann
drohen weitere menschen leben in dieser
krise verloren zu gehen weitere menschen
zu sterben und darüber wollen wir
sprechen mit einem intensivmediziner und
chefarzt der professoren sind schön dass
sie da sind vielen dank für ihre zeit ja
gute lahm zusammen
sagen sie uns einmal wie ist die lage
auf den deutschen intensivstationen eads
seit tagen nicht sagt den jetzt mal
ehrlich seit wochen angespannt wir
weisen übrigens auch schon seit wochen
darauf hin so richtig hat man uns nicht
gehört
aber so langsam angesichts dieser doch
dramatisch steigenden zahlen habe ich
den eindruck da ist es angekommen und
vielleicht musste es erst diese zahl
30.000 diese abstruse zahl geknackt
werden vielleicht mussten erst pro tag
nahezu 600 menschen versterben dass
endlich endlich mal hoffentlich eine
einigkeit in einer corona politik wie
ich sie auch immer nennen möchte
einkehrt dass endlich mal 16
ministerpräsidenten ministerpräsidenten
wirklich mit einer stimme sprechen und
sie haben es ja in der diskussion vorher
schon gerade klar dargestellt ich glaube
die verunsicherung der letzten wochen
ist so immens dass die bevölkerung
wirklich nicht mehr weiß was sie tun
soll aber wir auf den intensivstationen
den krankenhäusern wir kriegen nur noch
eines mit nämlich dass der druck auf den
mitarbeitern enorm geworden ist und ich
sage ihnen ganz ehrlich 1 die stehen
nicht mit dem rücken zur wand die sind
einfach fertig caputs wir haben jetzt
wochenlang schwerkranke cupid 19 nicht
cupid 19 patienten behandelt und können
zum teil nicht mehr und gegen jetzt in
ein weihnachtsfest rhein wo sie nämlich
am bett der patienten stehen während
andere zu hause feiern wie jedes jahr
das machen die gerne aber dieses jahr
wird es besonders hart
wenn wir dann miterlebt hätten das dann
noch die lockerungen wieder aufgehen
wieder zehn leute zusammenkommen und im
januar die situation sich noch mehr
verschafft dann wird es ganz bitter
werden und für uns sehr schwierig werden
deshalb unser appell
haben sie gerade gesagt ist es ganz
wichtig dass jetzt die politik endlich
mit einer stimme spricht können sie uns
ganz konkret sagen welche maßnahmen
jetzt getroffen werden müssen auch was
muss ich am wochenende geeinigt werden
damit die intensivstation vor allem
wieder entlastet werden
es ist doch eines vollkommen klar london
lite oder wie das immer genannt lloyd
wright ist der richtige ausdruck dafür
gewesen dass das gewese ist sie haben
die bilder doch den letzten wochen
gesehen sie haben auch die ansturm in
den verein kaufte straßen gesehen auch
wenn die leute damals getan glauben wir
doch nicht dass in den geschäften hier
keine aero sohle entstehen die dann doch
zu infektionen führen und auch im
privaten umfeld muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen haben wir schon den eindruck dass
wir wenn wir das beobachten wo denn die
infektion herkommen tatsächlich hier
auch viele infektionsketten in gang
gesetzt also es ist doch vollkommen klar
kontaktieren verbote müssen ob sich
eingeführt werden denn das zulassen auf
die persönliche verantwortung des
einzelnen bauen das hat einfach nicht
funktioniert und so anders ist es
gezeigt von kontakt ihr uns verboten bis
hin zur ausgangssperren ein bisschen zu
wirklich schließen von den geschäften
das sind die maßnahme die gezogen haben
deshalb müssen wir uns nichts neues
ausdenken wir müssen übrigens auch nur
das machen was wir schon in früher
gemacht haben immerhin das ist doch eine
blaupause gewesen da haben wir doch
gezeigt dass es funktioniert hat und
jetzt tun wir uns so schwer damit und
diskutieren uns wirklich durch die woche
durch wir intensiv medizin haben vier
bis fünfmal so viele patienten in den
krankenhäusern in auf den
intensivstationen wie noch im frühjahr
und können es einfach nicht glauben und
verstehen
an uns ist da vorbei diskutiert worden
wir haben immer gesagt so geht es nicht
mehr weiter
und jetzt haben wir aus unserer sicht
die notbremse gezogen
jetzt ist corinna natürlich kein
deutschland problem sondern eine
weltweite pandemie was können wir
vielleicht vor allem von unseren
nachbarn lernen hier in europa
beispielsweise von belgien irland oder
vielleicht auch frankreich ja schön
diese venen also ich kann ihnen nur
raten
google reinzugehen und corona cupid 19
usd von und die länder mal eingeben da
sehen sie sofort die einzelnen länder
mit in den kampf zu zahlen da sehen sie
waren sie den lockdown gemacht haben den
harten oder ich würde sagen der begriff
ist verkehrt ist kein nachteil sein
durchgreifender lockt an dieser stadt
sind dann sehr wie die infektionszahlen
untergehen und sie sehen deutschland
schwebt in ungeahnten höhen mit seinen
group 1906 ions haben das muss uns doch
einfach zeigen und den beweis liefern
dass diese maßnahmen die zum teil
wirklich noch drastischer sind als das
was man früher gemacht haben einfach
erfolg zeigen und das müssen wir jetzt
einfach auch durchziehen ich glaube bei
aller sorge die ich wirklich und
verständnis für die wirtschaft habe und
es ist wirklich furchtbar zu sehen wie
viele leute auch darunter leiden weil
sie vielleicht ihr geschäft verlieren
weil sie ihre arbeit verloren haben aber
das leben am ende zu verlieren und die
ganze gesellschaft zusammenbrechen zu
lassen ich glaube das ist nicht das was
wir wollen wir müssen jetzt als
gesellschaft zusammen stehen und durch
diese harte zeit durch den aber uns rein
stottern ins nächste jahr und danach
monatelang jeden tag die gleiche
diskussion führen ich glaube das ist
jetzt endlich mal vorbei wir brauchen
jetzt einen klaren weg und ich glaube
die leute sind irgendwann auch froh dass
sie diesen weg aufgezeigt bekommen und
ich bitte wirklich darum dass nicht
wieder
übermorgen jeder ministerpräsident ohne
ministerpräsidenten sich wieder was
neues einfallen lässt das machen wir in
der medizin auch nicht in der medizin
haben patienten behandeln wir nach
gültigen standards und denken uns nicht
alle fünf minuten eine neue therapie aus
bitte liebe politiker übernimmt dort das
vorgehen der mediziner deutschland ist
im augenblick ein patient und der
braucht eine gute behandlung und zwar
eine stimmige und deine übereinstimmen
sehr eindringliche worte fielen dank
professor jahns noch mal für diese
einblicke auf die intensivstation hier
bei uns im ganzen land dankeschön
ich danke mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei blaulicht hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren